millions of Americans have been working
from home during this pandemic but now
the covet restrictions are disappearing
so many large employers are saying to
their employees come back to the office
later today Congress will consider
offering many federal employees to
return as well Scott McFarland is in
Bethesda Maryland with more on that
Scott I wonder how employees are feeling
about that order
we're about to find out Gail three years
into the pandemic as review of federal
records by CBS News finds more than a
million federal workers are working at
least part of the week at home
Republicans want to bring that number
back to pre-pandemic levels and bring
many of those workers back to the office
it's a telework Monday not so bad across
the metro area with overall lower travel
volumes when covid arrived a mass
migration to telework followed including
for federal workers I love it Valencia
McIntyre Dubose who for 23 years has
processed benefits for the U.S
Department of Veterans Affairs and
helped the employee union says she's
never been more efficient now that she's
working from home you think it's helping
to retain more federal workers being
able to telework yes it's easier you can
get the job done and it seems to me that
by me doing the telework I get my work
done faster and easier the number of U.S
government employees telecommuting has
more than doubled since 2018 but in a
vote later today the U.S house now under
Republican control is pushing a plan to
bring most federal workers back as the
threat of covet is receding everybody
should come back to the office and do
what the American people have to do
certainly if you're federal employee the
standard ought to be higher many private
businesses are already pushing workers
to get back to the office most of the
time including Starbucks Goldman Sachs
Disney and Apple CEO Tim Cook explained
to CBS morning's Nate Burleson you
collaborate with one another because we
believe that one plus one equals three
and and and so that takes the
Serendipity of running into people that
doesn't mean that we're going to be in
here five days we're not the Republican
chair of the house oversight committee
argues backlogs at the IRS during tax
season and slowdowns in processing
Social Security checks and Veterans
Benefits could be reduced if employees
got back to the office is the rest of
America went back to work in person many
federal workers did not and the American
people have suffered as a result also
weighing in are democratic mayors of
some major cities including New York San
Francisco Houston and Washington where
telework has squeezed some local
businesses an empty downtown buildings
America wins when the place where people
come to join and change the world is
buzzing but some Democrats in Congress
are pushing back against the current
bill we cannot enter a time machine and
simply disappear the utility of telework
in recruiting and retaining new
generations of federal workers advocates
for the roughly 1 million teleworking
federal employees say an end to telework
could trigger a wave of retirements
resignations and further backlogs we
need an Effective Government to solve
some of our biggest problems and
Effective Government needs great talent
the greatest benefit of telework is that
it helps us attract and keep the best
people possible to serve the public
this U.S house plan to reduce telework
will likely pass along party lines today
the U.S Senate won't take it up so it'll
stall for a while but Tony house aides
tell CBS news they could make this part
of the negotiations later this year to
prevent a government shutdown
I'll have to think about there Scott
thank you very much